what's up guys david ahmadi here from
gamespot alongside with aaron sampson
and this week we've got a lot to break
down last time when we had the shooter
chat there wasn't really a lot going on
in the shooter space call of duty
battlefield and even overwatch were kind
of all treading water and now all of a
sudden everything seems to be happening
at once so we're gonna talk about the
new season three for call of duty we're
gonna talk about how overwatch two is
really overwatch 1.5 and we're also
going to talk about how battlefield had
over like 400 things wrong with the game
apparently
i didn't honestly know there were 400
things wrong with the game
neither did i and i mean to be honest
i'll be really surprised so let's get to
it so we're getting task force 141 back
we're getting the band back together
anybody who played the last game kind of
knew that people were a little freaking
out a little bit at the beginning of the
week wondering if we were going to get
an announcement that the game was coming
soon
um but they weren't going to compete
with with warzone their king kong
godzilla event then it later came out
that yeah of course like we're going to
hear about it later this year but man i
don't envy them they have two completely
different crowds to please now so like
you've got to know that you're
developing modern warfare
2
this year for the modern warfare 2019
crowd who are the milsim crowd who don't
like crazy clowns in their games like
they just want they want like more
grounded weighty combat they want the
original warzone then they're gonna
maybe take a break for a year that it
might last two years which is great for
that crowd because they cut off modern
warfare 2019 way too soon they were like
guns that still hadn't come out it just
felt super abrupt it was like a big
takeover that turned a lot of people off
but then you got to realize after that
it's like the cold war crowds turn
uh i don't know if you want to make them
wait for two years
they're the people who love classic call
of duty they like it fast you know they
like it more arcadey they like it snappy
they like that quick movement so like
they really need to get wrap their head
around the fact that
warzone is never really going to please
both audiences and
maybe the war zone doesn't like
incorporate every call of duty game
every year now david you hopped in and
checked out you know what's going on
with season three and the
you know the potential king kong fight
so what's going on there so yeah season
three went live a lot of the changes
were kind of like incremental there's a
lot of hints and a lot of like teases
because the big thing obviously is isn't
really gonna happen until may 11th which
is king kong and godzilla just duking it
out it's almost reminds me of like when
you're a kid and you have the two big
action figures and you just start
smashing them together the main things
that kind of changed with warzone uh
were there were some map changes so you
have these like ruins with like a bunch
of bones and stuff like that you see
like dinosaur bones and rib cages and
things like that around runway peak and
lagoon uh and then another thing that
was actually kind of cool was like
there's kind of like a new gulag uh
looks a little different which is fun
but for the most part it's just typical
war zone other than you know your slew
of new skins and a new battle pass and
things like that kind of like uh those
little incremental content updates for
people to sink their teeth into for a
bit but the main thing really is going
to be the big king kong event uh the
king congress godzilla event which i'm
excited for and one thing that's
interesting to me about those events is
they really seem to be taking a leap out
of fortnite's book and how they're
approaching this where they start
teasing those events first they start
kind of showing you the little changes
around the map before the big event
happens and i'm really curious to see
how they're gonna do that because it's
only it boggles my mind that we always
think that bullets are gonna actually do
something to these big behemoths it
never works it just pisses them off and
so you know we'll see if uh you know how
you're supposed to take them down are
you just gonna watch them fight are you
just gonna be a spectator are you gonna
go in with a little you know
with an ar and see if you can take down
godzilla yourself i mean you can clean
his toenails with an ar but that's about
all you're gonna do
it's gonna be yeah like i don't know
maybe it'll be like team godzilla versus
like team king kong and you help each
one of them fight each other but
yeah that's gonna be interesting to see
what happens when you have things on the
map that just get angry when you shoot
them all right so moving on to
battlefield now this is particularly
funny to me because aaron you said it
best could we have even considered that
there was actually over 400 things wrong
with the game that we just had no idea
about yeah it makes a lot more sense why
season one got delayed although i would
still argue that i can't believe they
didn't have season one more or less in
the can when they launched the game
this is gonna you know this quote's
gonna keep coming back to bite them but
you know remember when they were talking
how ahead of schedule they were in all
their production
somebody just wasn't talking to somebody
else in the company at that time when
they made that statement so it turns out
that they just really wanted to start
this you know what they want is to be a
redemption arc by changing the core
mechanics of the game so what they're
trying to do it seems like is fix the
under the hood mechanics and then move
forward on the game now the problem is
out of these 400 changes the only stuff
that people really cared about
wasn't changed so you know
people ask for voice chat they got that
people ask for a scoreboard they got
that but those were so insignificant
to the like overwhelming
opinion that they just need to wrestle
these
specialists back into a class system and
they made some changes like to their
credit um so
row and pake kind of changed abilities a
bit so these have both turned into
more useful
sort of like combat recon class
characters they're all about visibility
and if you have them on your front line
like i just played a bunch of
breakthrough like as long as they're
shooting or getting shot at your team is
very aware of who's around you so that
was really cool like this i've said this
all along battlefield 2042 is
inconsistent
which means sometimes it is super fun
you have that battlefield moment like i
was playing with rao i was playing
breakthrough i was like shutting down
vehicles i was the explosions were going
off i was tossing c4 like it was pretty
fantastic in that moment right but then
a couple rounds later like
you'll just be on sort of an open map
without enough cover which is something
they want to change in the future and it
just doesn't work right like okay all
right so we were like we're trying to
start our redemption arc we start with
400 changes yeah good on you dice like
honestly like if if we're gonna make
this work
that makes sense now why we're so
delayed it's because there was so much
wrong with the game fundamentally
step two is get your specialists in line
um which some of these changes kind of
started doing
and then
step three is like get your darn season
one out the door because
yeah that's that's where i left i made
it up to level 50 i had a decent time
i didn't hate things as much as other
people did but i understand why they
hated it but when season one got delayed
it was like well why am i here so yeah
that's that's that's the road map so far
do you remember the first trailer with a
row
and how he hacked somebody and then took
them out and you and i were like we're
like
that's not how it works like
you shoot people first
yeah
it's just it's this overarching theme in
battlefield where it's like they just
didn't seem to know what the game was
that they were making for some reason
you know a lot of our audience have
pointed out i think a lot of the core
battlefield developers left over time so
maybe it was just a new crew i really
hope if they want this redemption arc
they really think about what this game
is and like what
what makes it good what makes
battlefield good
originally i think we were going to talk
about halo
infinite season 2 but people weren't too
enthused about that online tell us if
you are enthused about it i can't tell
sometimes if it's just like screaming
youtubers or like the actual audience um
so if you want us to cover that next
time as well as a lot of you mentioned
apex in our previous video um tell us if
you want to cover that too because
people say that game's in a really good
place but where where that landed david
and i was on overwatch too and david you
had a chance to
play the beta um what do you think i
mean i know it says beta but like this
is a true beta you know it's not a demo
it's not a complete or finished build by
any means and so a lot of my feelings
and opinions uh there should be an
asterisk on this you know of course the
final product may change there might be
new things involved we don't really know
yet but from what i saw
how i felt was
it was okay you know whenever that game
finally comes out there's supposed to be
pve uh a deeper story because that game
has such a rich
rich rich world and lore of characters
right that hero shooter it kind of like
almost you know i i don't want to throw
the word around lightly but it really
did kind of pioneer the fact of having a
multiplayer-centric game but with a
whole just lively story in the
background that other games like apex
kind of uh was influenced by and so this
beta unfortunately did not have any pve
which is what i was looking forward to
instead it was mainly 5v5 quick play
unranked uh pvp which
really put the game into a situation of
it being a overwatch 1.5 so with 5v5
they removed the tank
and the removal of that tank to me was
actually a nice change because when
you have two tanks i felt like
i feel like those those those firefights
were just ending in stalemates so often
because those tanks were obviously just
absorbing all of the damage they're
being constantly buffed or healed by you
know supporting characters and it made
it just it prolonged so many um
engagements that i kind of was like
getting almost fatigued or exhausted and
so having one tank really puts the
significant emphasis on which tank
you're gonna pick because the way that
overwatch uh tanks are kind of set up at
least in my opinion you tend to have
like i want to say like the prototypical
tank like a reinhardt or a roadhog and
then you have like tank lights or like
off tanks like a diva you know and now
if you decide to commit to like adiva
azarya you really do have to commit and
i'm really curious to see uh as blizzard
gets player feedback what they're gonna
do with the tank meta because when you
only have one tank there's so much
emphasis so much importance set around
that like your whole team is kind of
revolving around that one tank now i'm
curious to see where they go from there
but overall the core like gameplay was
still fine it's interesting this game's
also been going for a long time a lot of
what you're saying also sounds like it's
just sort of a 1.5
yeah and like
people are kind of dying for well i
don't know are people dying for a sequel
to these games or they just want to keep
going with what they got
it's like this weird
gray zone of
how
how hungry are you for something new
versus how
familiar do you want the game to be and
for me personally i think the way that
the game felt it felt a little too
familiar i personally was hoping for for
something a little more substantial
people just aren't made to play the same
thing forever although maybe there's
like a comfort food level to it like you
play a lot of destiny and it's kind of
nice to just have that thing you can do
at the end of the night that you know
how long it's going to take you know
it's going to feel good
like you you just want the comfort of
that because your day is rough right
yeah it's so there's a danger between
there's like this risk reward between a
developer completely redeveloping a game
or continuing to give people what
they're comfortable with as you said
yeah that's it's a really interesting
point jessie's grappling with this
rainbow six he's just grappling with
this apex uh to a lesser extent but
still
and and overwatch all grappling with
this idea of like when do you when do
you move on to the next game
you know and and i think i mean i i you
know the guys in the comments correct me
if i'm wrong here but like when
overwatch 2 was first announced
it was a really there was a lot of
confusing marketing around it where
you know you need a reason you need a
compelling reason to swap or to upgrade
you know and they really didn't come out
with much other than are you interested
in pve because that's the only thing
that overwatch 2 offers that overwatch
one possibly cannot offer but they had
mentioned like oh all your heroes and
your skins and everything from overwatch
one
is going to be active in overwatch too
which is which is nice but that also
kind of minimizes a reason to drop 60 or
70 bucks
on a new game because you're just
playing the same game that you've
already been playing like that makes no
sense to me so if you if you were not
interested in pve if that's not
something that you're looking forward to
if you're watching a twitch stream right
now hoping to get a pvp beta because
that's all you really want is that 5v5
like is it really worth jumping that
upgrade and the truth is is that i'm not
entirely sure
you know they actually there was one
thing i was really looking forward to
was trying to see if they did um a
different game mode when you get to the
classic quickplay modes it's really
one of two
um game modes it's escorting a payload
so you're either attacking or defending
or it is controlling an objective which
is like a best of three
and you know you just hold the zone for
a certain amount of time and you know a
little percentage progress bar tracks up
and if you hit 100 you know you win
right
you play these two modes ad nauseum for
years and years and years and it's like
you know like you said maybe it's
comfort food for some people but like
is that really all there is you know
like that's why when arcade modes come
out in overwatch one you have capture
the flags sometimes or you have those
other ones i leap for those moments
because i'm like oh this is great like i
get to play the core gameplay loop that
i enjoy i get to play with my friends
but i get at least a different taste and
so when overwatch 2
when i hopped into the pvp i was like
there's got to be at least one new game
mode and there was it was a payload mode
but it was like a split payload so
instead of having one attack team and
one defending team uh and you control an
objective and then a payload comes out
and you have to escort it or you know
prevent the team from escorting in what
you had was you had this one like
kind of like goofy looking robot omnic
guy in the middle of the arena and if
you basically like hovered around the
robot he would walk over towards a wall
there was two colored walls one for each
team and he would just push the wall so
it was basically another payload and he
would push the wall as far as he
possibly could and then you know
whenever the enemy team would hang over
next to the robot then the robot would
just 180 walk all the way back to
wherever the other wall was and then
start pushing matt and there was a timer
and by the time the timer counted down
you basically were judged on how far
your wall was pushed and if your wall
was pushed further you won
what like like it was a game mode of
just like you know basically the robot
just switched allegiances based on if he
had friends like the robot was just
lonely and if like whoever was around
him he'd be like i'm gonna help you now
and then he'd just start like marching
across the map super slowly it just it
made no sense to me well all right we
want to see if your opinions have
changed from just a couple of weeks ago
when the entire you know first person
third-person shooter space was really
dry we asked some of you what you were
playing and we're gonna go over here to
matthew drake who said i find him
currently playing no modern competitive
fps's really i played halo for a hot
minute i jammed on valorent for a while
too but that was all last year the only
fps i play now are either pve like
cyberpunk 2077 and back for blood or
other competitive shooters like
overwatch it's kind of crazy to think
about the hype we had last fall and how
the three biggest fps franchises halo
call of duty and battlefield kind of you
know
they put dot dot dot but i think they
mean dropped off so let us know what you
guys are playing now like
has your mind changed are you hopping in
the beta are you gonna hop in for the
godzilla war zone event do you think
battlefield has maybe started its
redemption arc let us know in the
comments below we always read the
comments and then we'll we'll dig back
in we we not only use those in the
shooter chat but we also make a lot of x
lists around shooters so like x things
that you guys are playing that aren't
call of duty and battlefield and we will
include what you say in those lists all
right thanks for watching everybody
[Music]
you